morris johnson swept it under the carpet
telling businesses to put customs forms
in the bin
and the government's still denying there
will be a border in the irish sea
despite pledging 350 million pounds
to support those trading across it
there's no paperwork that businesses
themselves will have to uh
fill out that will be unnecessary
onerous or
problematic because unfettered access is
guaranteed
from northern ireland to gp and the
trader support service that we're
putting in place
lifts the bureaucratic burden from
business
there'll be 200 million pounds to
digitalize checks on goods moving from
great britain to northern ireland
and a further 150 million pounds for new
technology
the northern ireland retail consortium
says that won't solve every problem
this is like a jigsaw and you cannot get
the full picture
until you've all the pieces in place and
while
looking after customs and tariffs and
and those costs that come from that is a
really good step
we need to look at fat we need to look
at access we need to look at
health certificates and until we do that
we simply won't know what the cost to
retailers and what the cost of consumers
will be there's a conflict in the
northern ireland part of the withdrawal
agreement
one part refers to checks in the irish
sea
another promises unfettered access
with this cache they're attempting to
streamline processes
it may be light touch but that's still a
border
between great britain and northern
ireland
cherry pipes limited has plants in two
counties they produce plastic drainage
pipes
for agriculture civil engineering and
sports grounds
with ninety percent of their business
being done outside northern ireland they
can't afford delays
we've invested nearly five million pound
in this large diameter pipe machine
and that is for the to grow our business
in the gb market
the difficulty come the 31st of december
but people say
your trucks will be delayed for a day
we're going into a market that we're
competing
with similar companies who manufacture
in the gb
a day late could be the difference from
winning and losing
with four months to produce a trade deal
michael gove met with first minister
arlene foster
the deputy first minister spoke to him
by phone shin fein said
she'd not received notice of the meeting
the challenges
still loom large david blevins sky news
in porterdine